[Music]
in not appropriate news uh-oh what did
you do nothing I never do anything
submitted by integrity you're a fraud
and don't ever know why isn't that I
know all right
a teacher resigned after she had her
10th grade class taking online morality
quiz that upset parents more laughing
wait what great entry and this is also a
language arts class why did she get in
trouble for it why are they taking
morality to this point today class we're
gonna do something different and who's
administering the murari test the
teacher no but who's who's coming up
with the questions how moral is that
[ __ ]
I understand philosophy and ethics but
language are exactly it's kind of like
head of the blue these are
fifteen-year-old questions like why so
this teacher she gave this moral
foundations test which I gave the link
to Stephen Joseph and Giovanna so you
guys have taken this moral test so you
know I guess I scored why'd you leave me
out on purpose you want to go take her
your meeting map it was just a meeting
okay it's my appointment my appointments
during their lifetime I like this test
you gave me well she's the one that gave
it to everyone that's how I found it
through this like a popular quiz no I
mean I don't think it's popular cuz I
haven't heard of it they have some
really funny questions
what's even more funnier to is I don't
think they were meant to be funny
but I couldn't stop laughing when I was
reading it me too in choice I just like
troubled sometimes girls like oh that's
the funniest answer I want to vote yeah
oh wait I don't wanna get a bad score
there's like one question where it's
like this girl tells her friend that she
wants to enter in a beauty pageant and
then she's like laughing in front of her
face and saying you're too fat and ugly
to do so and I was like that is so
[ __ ] hilarious and I wouldn't put
double thumbs up but then I was like
that's so mean
that's not what the question that would
hurt my feelings
I said one thumbs down take this test if
they have to determine so there's gonna
be like a statement and you have to turn
you have to determine whether it's not
okay or okay so this is one example it
says a man orders a custom-built sex
doll designed to look just like his
niece is that not okay you're okay
there's like a little sliders and you
get to choose a scale yeah so I feel
like mostly not okay but if some
circumstances Oh kidding just give the
one yeah like right here
cuz this would be like fully not okay
see I was always told though when you'd
like when you do like a personality quiz
and it's like never and always and then
there's the ones in between that it's
what you get a more accurate result if
you just go all the way at the end or
all the way at the right cuz putting
some what it kind of like it's like
you're not being very clear on it should
be a yes-or-no thing well some of it is
hard to kind of determine for sure but
it's a cop-out by doing them yeah I'm
not a hundred percent sure because
there's so many circumstances so more is
it neutral like I was trying to go as
hard yes or hard no as much as I could
but their son that like I had to stay
neutral cuz I'm like what what if that
option wasn't there it was just yes or
it's just no I would probably leave it
blank because I don't think either one
of the no and it didn't let you continue
on with the quiz and I'll throw away the
quiz there is no black and one there
should be a neutral least right or you
should be able to be like I don't want
anything to do with this there's like it
wasn't a pie these are questions that I
often ask myself like where I see say I
see Kate Upton and she's wearing a hot
dress whatever and then she's pictured
next to her dad at some awards show
thing and I'm like does he know she's
[ __ ] hot like does he know that yeah
yeah I'm saying so I'm like so the knees
question I'm like what if your niece was
Kate Upton I'm like yeah exactly that's
why it's there's so many except what if
your niece is always in you right yeah
there you go sometimes your knees can be
older really yeah like let me have an
old ass [ __ ] sister right and had a
kid before you were even born that's a
very good point
cuz I have a niece that's 33 I'm older
than her but I mean it in a couple of
years if the the births were time yes
shut up 1037c the same age as you
question says losing both a condom and
the pill a brother in suit and his
sister decide that they want to sleep
with each other just once to see what it
would be like I voted yeah for this is
that not okay no that's box I thought it
was fine that's faster that was fine
yeah I thought it was fine brother and
sister can [ __ ] and that's chill they
have double protection but this is one
of those things where you don't know
each your assuming their age no no this
is one of those things where I didn't
vote hell yes that's your favorite porn
category so maybe that's not my favorite
one is menage with tois anyway okay
you're not even entertaining the thought
even spell Vanaja top threesome this is
what's what people are doing they're
filling in the blanks within what they
think it is okay right that but let's
read that statement objectively if a
brother and a sister decides to use
protection a condom and a pill just to
experience what it feels like to have
sex together
right there's still brother and sister
[ __ ] that is but that's your friend
and that's how you anymore but 16 my
mutton I'm not okay I mean like I won't
want to [ __ ] my brother or sister that's
not me what out you have a brother I
agree with Joe a little bit because the
way the question structured is if these
two people that are not you want to do
that then it's like well why the [ __ ] am
I like trying to butt in with my own
morals but it's a moral quiz it's a
singular world and answering
I think it's immoral than to be like I'm
gonna judge them for doing some [ __ ]
because they have their own moral but
you also know and what also it's it's
two scales right so I want the more and
this specific question the more moral
you are the less accepting you are to
that's what if they're like hey if
people's brothers and sisters want to
[ __ ] each other you say okay the damage
are extremely accepting person like
Mother Teresa so to wrap up my point
mother Teresa probably wouldn't be
Dallin brother sister [ __ ] most other
people not hurt but to wrap up my point
what people are getting confused with
is confusing desire immorality so when
people think this it's like would I be
okay with it would I [ __ ] my brothers
sister that's what they're putting
themselves in related that are [ __ ]
right okay with it and that's all
anyone's ask buddies are you okay with
its to consent oh no and you know what
now like I've been very opposed to this
but what if it's a situation where they
don't even know each other like what if
exactly there's so many different and
they don't know each other but they're
wearing condoms and pills and all it's
like white so much protection that clean
is one of them [ __ ] a Hilda beast
what if like they meet each other and
it's like oh you're over there you're a
sister [ __ ] I'm already attracted to you
like I already I met you at a bar and
now I'm attracted to you and I wanted
we've done articles we're brothers and
sisters who were warm and then they came
together but father
daughters a little bit different from
brother and sister too they fell in love
he said come on over baby and then just
like don't looks like my dad in that
picture and then he's like oh that's my
dad that has happened yeah and then he's
like I am your dad you are my baby
oh come on over a shameless oh really
or what if you are dog breeder and you
only have two golden retrievers left in
their brothers and sister no that's bad
that happens all the time happens all
the time brothers and sisters [ __ ] each
other in the dog world I wonder if the
dads who are with their daughters like
we've done those articles before it's
like that's like come on baby it's like
is it weird that I say that and you're
my baby with it for the record I went
far No yeah me too
so that means you're very not a very
accepting person you're my I did a
little yes B not cool with brother
sister [ __ ] it makes me a not open
person then I'm a not open person this
other question Adam and Beth have been
dating for three years
Adam is reluctant to have children so
Beth tells him that she's on the pill
when she is it that's [ __ ] up that's
being a [ __ ] no see that's worse
their brother-sister [ __ ] cuz the
point is there is no consent
yeah notice that's a trick and you're
bringing a life into this world
I got moral that's reckless what about
this other one in sex education class
the students are taught that since the
sexes are equal the girls should sleep
with as many guys as they want without
fear of being considered [ __ ] in a sex
education class yeah I agree I agree I
agree I caught three thumbs up I did one
thumbs oh I did multiple I did as many
thumbs up guys I could as many guys as
they want that kind of makes it weird
for me the fact that I think so I'm like
don't have to type algebra so this is
the class to teach them what you can do
no hiding guns yeah you know like I'm
thinking high school like you don't know
what their parents morals are like what
they even feel like you remember sex ed
though when the teacher was like boys ha
ha
have your way with it boy I think it's
in the wording so some people are
getting caught up and you should be able
to have sex with as many boys as you
want period that's what they're getting
caught up with but if you follow it up
with without the fear of being called a
[ __ ]
then it all it's trying to say is like
oh you don't have to worry about being
called a [ __ ]
so it depends on what part of that
sentence you're focusing yeah but we've
taken [ __ ] back now [ __ ] is cool now hey
[ __ ] thanks mark I put a little no
because the sex education class yeah me
on I feel like all of its actually okay
but the focus is the sex I don't know
cuz for me if it wasn't sex education
I'd be we're like I don't want my kids
learn about fashion economics education
perfect you're supposed to learn that
comes but I do think like in a sex ed
class like it is an open environment and
regardless of what the parents are
teaching them at home it is just a fact
that you should be a lot your body is
yours and if you want to sleep with 20
million men because you want you then
that's fine because you want to and it's
not up to anybody else so decide if your
ass up for that secondly I've always
wondered this where it's like if you're
a girl and you have sex eight times a
day with eight different people or if
you have sex eight times a day with the
same man who's a bigger [ __ ] cuz to me
you're getting powered eight times a day
that's pretty [ __ ] so who cares if
it's eight different dudes doesn't it
matter with like spreading diseases and
[ __ ] but let's say
eight bats yes a she's a very responsive
condom inside she's got a big condom
budget and she's doing it very often
she's got boxes in the garage who's a
bigger [ __ ] to me oh I think for me when
I read that question I don't think it's
appropriate conversation to be having in
a sex ed class that's what I was
thinking yeah why do you want to have a
pee where it's like you should be able
to sleep with as many people as you want
it's more you call the see what I don't
know if that's something that should be
taught in a sex ed class it's excess
should be like this is what time into
your body this is the science no but
it's so boring though they should teach
these guys how to work the [ __ ] play
yeah did your mother work the couch side
that's what I've been saying yeah that's
gonna be sexy it should be human
sexuality yeah that's why I went with a
little bit of yes because I'm like yes I
like that you'd like no it's equal like
we're treated equal I forgot about that
said I didn't feel it was okay to teach
it in sex ed because when you go to
college or whatever you start learning
about human sexuality and then it's all
that other [ __ ] that makes it stick to
the side no pretty young so teaching
work that was straight girls to work the
balls I think that's important how to
suck a dick correctly
[Music]